Uh, and also when it comes to his role with
Donald Trump last week I told you that, you
know, things have gone off the beaten path
when we are judging how a president is doing,
not by their approval rating, but by the level
of support for their impeachment, which is
the way that things have shifted with Donald
Trump.
But there's an even more stunning metric,
which is how many people want Donald Trump
imprisoned, nevermind impeached.
And now a majority of democratic voters in
those early primary States.
The States that will be voting in the first
few months of 2020 they don't just believe
that Donald Trump should be impeached, but
a majority of early democratic primary state
voters believe that Donald Trump should be
imprisoned.
A 53% in Iowa, 50% in New Hampshire, 54% of
Democrats in South Carolina are saying, not
just that Donald Trump should be impeached
and removed from office, but that he should
be imprisoned.
Now, these are stunning numbers, but does
this matter because this is in the end, just
democratic primary voters.
There are some of the most politically involved
people, arguably some of the more partisan
people that you could pull.
Does it really matter?
And the answer is that in a vacuum, it really
doesn't.
All of these indicators are merely sort of
proxies to whether Donald Trump might be voted
out in November a record 69% for example,
say that they disliked Donald Trump personally.
Okay.
Does it matter?
It matters if it gets people to go and vote
in November for somebody other than Donald
Trump.
Support for impeaching and removing Donald
Trump is higher than ever.
Even among Republicans.
As I told you last week, in the two weeks
or so since the beginning of the Ukraine fiasco
support among Republicans for the impeachment
inquiry has roughly tripled from about 11%
to about 30 does that matter?
Well, it matters if it affects how people
vote in November of 2020 it matters if it
keeps enough Republicans from voting at all
that it will allow the democratic base to
get somebody else elected other than Donald
Trump in November of 2020 in a sense, the
headline majority of early voters want Trump
in prison, could be rewritten much less hyperbolically
as majority of early voters can recognize
when crimes have been committed period, but
unless it actually creates a certain action
in November of 2020 it's really moot.
The entire fiasco is really illuminating.
One of the most important differences between
Democrats and Republicans, which is that Democrats
want Trump held, responsible, impeached, investigated,
may be imprisoned.
Whatever you believe is appropriate for the
crimes that he's clearly committed for.
The way that he has clearly sold out our sovereignty
to foreign powers.
Republicans want Hillary Clinton in prison
because they don't like her, and Trump said,
lock her up and they've been successfully
brainwashed into thinking something about,
or emails means she should go to prison.
There's an above the law component that's
visible here with Trump and his cronies that
if we don't root it out, it could not only
take hold, but it could grow and it's terribly
toxic for the United States of America.
Now you know I'm not someone who just defends
Democrats.
I've told you on tons of issues, there's no
practical difference between Democrats and
Republicans for the most part on reinforcing
the status quo of campaign finance.
Democrats and Republicans are basically the
same with some example, some exceptions.
Bernie's plan to get money out of politics
is a very good one.
Andrew Yang has such a plan.
There are Democrats who have plans, but there's
not a lot of air in terms of like your mainstream
elected officials between the two parties
on that issue.
For the most part, Democrats and Republicans
are almost equally complicit in reinforcing
the status quo of the military industrial
complex and the wide reaching, uh, tentacles
of the Pentagon and the American military.
There are some exceptions, but there are areas
of difference, and I've pointed out this one
before, when the left finds out that someone
in their ranks is a problem, we want to get
that person out because they're hurting the
movement.
There are distractions.
We don't want to cover it up.
We want to expose it and get that person out
sometimes to a fault.
Look at what happened with Al Frank and now
in retrospect, what are those Democrats who
said, Al Franken should resign?
Probably went too far on the right.
They want to cover it up.
They want to cover for that person, period.
And of course, the hypocrisy of thinking that
their people above the law are, are above
the law is a stark contrast with the democratic
party.
Some may actually be so disconnected from
reality that they really believe Donald Trump
hasn't done anything wrong and Democrats are
just being mean.
But I believe at this point that most of them
are plainly happy to just cover for Trump
with any old excuse they can come up with
as a logical as that may be.
And unless we get out and vote in November
of 2020, they well may get away with it.
And that's the scariest part of all of this.
Make sure you are following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David talkin show.
While you're there, follow me at David dot
package